Marco Rubio is entertaining all this UFO
stuff do you find many of them credible
well I don't find them either not
credible or credible because we have no
basis about we understand some of these
claims are things that are Beyond sort
of the realm of what any of us has ever
dealt with I will say I find most of
these people at some point or maybe even
currently have held very high clearances
and high positions within our government
so you start out you do ask yourself
like what incentive would so many people
with that kind of um qualification these
are serious people have to come forward
and make something up UFOs are just
little things that we see in the sky
that defy physical explanation I don't
want to just be like the guy in the
History Channel it's demons guys it's
just it's it's just demons that's what
it is Walsh solid Catholic guy but he
falls into this thing the UFO stuff the
alien stuff which is just demonology for
Liberal atheists